y
[Música]
la atención se mantiene en colombia'
después de una noche de violencia en las
calles que dejaron al menos diez muertos
cientos de heridos y decenas de
instalaciones de policía destruidas en
bogotá a llamados para que esta noche no
se repitan las fuertes protestas contra
la brutalidad policial tras la muerte
del abogado javier ordóñez quien fue
violentamente sometido por dos oficiales
otro incendio estalló en el puerto de
beirut una enorme columna de humo nubló
la capital libanesa reavivando el temor
de la ciudadanía poco más de un mes
después de la explosión que devastó el
puerto de la ciudad y mató a más de 190
personas el gobierno dice que el
incendio podría ser un acto intencional
de sabotaje el resultado de un error
técnico ignorancia o negligencia
la disminución de la vida silvestre en
las últimas décadas no se había visto en
millones de años en especial en américa
latina' eso concluye el informe planeta
vivo 2020 del fondo mundial para la
naturaleza la organización ecologista
también advierte que dañar los
ecosistemas aumenta el riesgo de que
aparezcan enfermedades infecciosas como
'el hobbit' 19
hola cómo están bienvenidos a esta
emisión de noticias aquí en france 24 mi
nombre es alan austria
empezamos en colombia donde no sé de la
rabia y la indignación social tras la
muerte de javier ordóñez un abogado y
padre de dos hijos que fue violentamente
retenido por la policía
la fuerte noche de protestas dejó un
saldo de al menos 10 muertos y para esta
jornada hay convocadas al menos 15
manifestaciones en medio de llamados a
la calma la violencia policial y los
actos de vandalismo dividen a la
ciudadanía reporte de lionel puse i
yo vi la luz al occidente de bogotá a
reflejar a arabia ciudadana la estación
de policía donde javier ordóñez pasó sus
últimos momentos antes de ser trasladado
a una clínica donde falleció fue el
epicentro de las protestas la
indignación de la ciudadanía está a flor
de piel
mira lo que pasó con la policía mataron
un muchacho como pasó en los eeuu le
colocaron electricidad a su cuerpo le
presionaron el pecho hasta me atraparon
le dieron patadas hasta que lo mataron
es más doloroso ver cómo dos niños se
quedan sin padre que pero nunca han
rallado eso es una estupidez al lado del
problema que en realidad se está
viviendo y que es de todos los días ayer
porque fue un muerto pero todos los días
vivimos los abusos de la gente de los
policías es sin embargo otro sector de
la ciudadanía rechaza los actos de
violencia por parte de los manifestantes
porque están en la forma de reaccionar o
sea uno puede llamar la atención es
decir oye las cosas no las hagan de esta
manera de una manera pacífica pero ya
cuando la cosa se convierte en
salvajismo cuando ya las personas actúan
de manera irracional no como seres
humanos sino irracionales porque el daño
que están haciendo ahorita es mucho más
grave porque es a nivel general cierto
ahorita estos costos nos sacan a
nosotros del bolsillo porque tenemos que
pagar impuestos de los daños que los que
se les ocurre hacer esta diligencia se
con la alcaldía de bogotá hay por lo
menos 15 manifestaciones convocadas para
la noche de los jueves y aunque no hay
toque de queda las autoridades piden
evitar estar en las calles de la capital
josé miguel vivanco director de la
división de las américas de human
rightswatch habló para nosotros en
francés 24 y se refirió a la necesidad
de una reforma policial en colombia
no cabe duda alguna que lo que le
ocurrió al abogado ordóñez fue un crimen
fue una brutal violación a los derechos
humanos cometida con alevosía por dos
agentes de la policía que ya lo tenían
bajo control y sin embargo se ensañaron
con él ahora este caso no es un caso
aislado hay múltiples denuncias que
nosotros hemos conocido y muy
recurrentes año tras año lo cual indica
que aquí la policía nacional debe ser
objeto de reformas de fondo reformas que
busquen mejorar la capacitación el
entrenamiento el manejo de armas letales
y armas obviamente no letales o menos
letales y sobre todo asegurarse que
cuente la policía con mecanismos
internos eficaces de control para
mantener la lo que es la disciplina
policial no ayuda que la policía siga
bajo las estructuras del ministerio de
defensa habría que trasladarlo al
ministerio de interior
tiempo tampoco ayuda que cuando hay
denuncia de esta naturaleza son
usualmente juzgadas por la justicia
penal militar como incluso el caso del
señor ordóñez donde se garantiza muchas
veces la impunidad de los autores de
estos delitos
el fuego volvió a alarmar beirut poco
más de un mes después de la doble
explosión que mató a casi 200 personas
en el puerto de la ciudad en la capital
libanesa cubierta por un denso humo
negro miles de personas trataron de huir
por temor a un nuevo estallido este
incendio afectó a un establecimiento
donde se almacenan latas de aceite y
llantas y se habría dado debido a la
negligencia oa un sabotaje según el
gobierno aún no se reportan víctimas
veamos el informe
como una tragedia que se repite un mes y
una semana después de la doble explosión
que arrasó con el puerto de beirut en la
misma zona se produjo un nuevo incendio
este jueves un galpón que contenía
aceite de neumáticos fue consumido por
el fuego los bomberos se apresuraron a
la escena y cruzaron las filas de
automóviles atrapados en el
embotellamiento ocasionado por
residentes que intentaban unir la red
tuve que evacuar a mi esposa e hijos
fuera de beirut para que no vieran lo
que estaba pasando porque todavía viven
con miedo de lo que pasó ante la nube
cubre casi toda la ciudad teníamos miedo
porque la explosión que destruyó beirut
ocurrió hace apenas un mes y le dan
barber group y ahí vemos que vuelve a
suceder lo mismo
karrar según el director interino del
puerto de beirut este fuego habría
estallado por el calor o por un error
pero el gobierno fue más allá o dafa
fajas mate raíz el presidente libanés
michel aún dice que el incendio de hoy
podría ser un acto internacional de
sabotaje el resultado de un error
técnico ignorancia o negligencia en
todos los casos la causa debe ser
conocida lo antes posible
les deben rendir cuentas uatae milésima
los testigos dicen que el almacén se
incendió mientras algunos empleados
realizaban trabajos de soldadura el
gobierno libanés solicitó una
investigación en otros temas las más de
12.000 personas que habitaban en el
campo de refugiados de memoria en la
isla griega de lesbos pasan su tercera
noche a la interperie después de que
éste fuera consumido por el fuego la
canciller alemana angela merkel confirmó
que es su país alemania además de
francia acogerán a por lo menos 400
menores no acompañados procedentes del
campo
estos serán repartidos entre diferentes
países de la unión europea que se unirán
a la iniciativa franco-alemana el primer
ministro griego kyriakos mitsotakis
había pedido apoyo para acoger a los
refugiados afectados
y finalizamos con temas ambientales y es
que la población animal mundial ha
disminuido en casi un 70% desde 1970
mientras que américa latina experimentó
una disminución del 94% según un nuevo
informe del fondo mundial para la
naturaleza el documento asegura que la
agricultura y la deforestación están
destruyendo cada vez más los hábitats
silvestres los autores piden mayores
esfuerzos de conservación y además que
las personas reduzcan drásticamente su
consumo de carne
un momento que es raro ver y que pronto
podría volverse aún más raro el informe
de wwf afirma que desde 1970 las
poblaciones animales mundiales han
disminuido en más de dos tercios es una
disminución acelerada que hemos estado
monitoreando durante 30 años y continúa
yendo en la dirección equivocada en 2016
documentamos una disminución del 60 por
ciento
ahora tenemos una disminución del 70 por
ciento todo esto pasa en un abrir y
cerrar de ojos en comparación con los
millones de años que muchas especies han
estado viviendo en el planeta el informe
asegura que la humanidad ha impactado el
75 por ciento de la tierra libre de
hielo del planeta y el 40% de los
océanos del mundo esto se debe a la
sobrepesca y la expansión agrícola
actividades que invaden los hábitats
naturales dejando a muchos animales con
pocos recursos para sobrevivir un tercio
de toda la tierra y la mayor parte del
agua dulce ahora se destinan a la
producción de alimentos lo que ha
provocado un consumo exagerado las
especies disminuyen más rápido en
algunas áreas que en otras en américa
latina' tuvo una caída
el 94% en comparación a las cifras en
1970 tenemos que actuar ahora las tasas
de recuperación de la biodiversidad
suelen ser mucho más lentas que las de
la reciente pérdida de la biodiversidad
a medida que los seres humanos siguen
invadiendo los hábitats naturales y
entran cada vez más en contacto con
animales salvajes también aumenta el
riesgo de futuras pandemias llegamos al
final de esta emisión les agradecemos su
compañía y cuídese cuídense mucho del
convite simple
[Música]